vous m'entendez les jeunes n'ayez pas peur
soyez concentré soyez déterminé ayez de l'espoir comme
la plupart des femmes je sais ce que ça fait d'être
négligée d'être sous-estimée d'avoir
quelqu'un qui n'écoute qu'à moitié vos idées
lors d'une réunion pour les voir se tourner vers l'homme
suivant  à vous l'homme que vous supervisez et
assumez qu'il est en charge
[Musique]
Je suis un enfant béni peut-être que je n'avais pas
beaucoup d'argent mais j'ai été béni avec l'
amour d'un père et d'une mère qui
m'ont donné des cadeaux qui n'avaient pas de prix et pour
cela  Je dois tellement alors je
pense à ça je pense à les rendre fiers
ils se sont battus
pour moi ils se sont sacrifiés ils ont sauvé j'avais
un frère aîné qui m'a précédé
mais ce n'était pas suffisant qu'il soit allé dans l'une
des meilleures universités du
pays je l'ai vu et j'ai pensé bien s'il
peut le faire je peux  fais-le parce que je sais que
je suis plus intelligent que lui
[Musique]
crois-le ou non quand nous nous sommes mariés pour la première fois,
notre facture mensuelle combinée de
prêt étudiant était en fait plus élevée que notre
hypothèque ouais nous étions si jeunes si
amoureux et si endettés
[Musique]
aujourd'hui, nous savons que nous ne pouvons plus laisser
nos enfants manger ce qu'ils veulent
[Musique]
nous devons changer ces notions selon lesquelles
les filles n'ont de valeur que pour leur
capacité de reproduction la capacité de
lire, d'écrire et d'analyser la confiance nécessaire pour
se lever et exiger  justice et égalité
tout cela commence par l'éducation
[Musique]
vous voyez dans cette course nous avons un
candidat dont la vision pour notre pays
manque complètement et totalement d'
espoir un candidat qui nous appelle à nous retourner les
uns contre les autres pour construire des murs pour être
peur
[Musique]